you know what they say like good artists  borrow great artists steal  I stole from Stan  I don't exist without the spirit of  Muhammad Ali all these comic books  wouldn't exist if Stan Lee hadn't  existed Tolkien had single-handedly just  created a viable genre Bella episode  showed me that change was possible she  made a space that belonged to women the  great Muhammad Ali will be relevant as  long as there are human beings on the  planet talking Dave the world permission  to dream  learn by looking at the Masters learn by  looking at somebody who did what you  want to do before you use them as a  treasure map  [Music]  thank you  [Applause]